I think that the time has come that
everybody
understands that this way of doing
things is impossible and it's not
sustainable that also the industry
understands that changes are needed and
that they are ready to make their
contribution to a better environment in
the future
[Music]
Mrs bursland thanks for being with us
the European Parliament is working on
several new initiatives related to
Consumer Protections and you were
leading one of them which is the updated
Ben commercial practices I know it's
still a negotiation but can you already
tell us what Parliament was to say
included in this list well I have to say
that I am quite proud of this work
because I believe that in the end it
will make a small Revolution for
consumers first of all let me say that
we want to protect consumers but also
the industry which is responsible and
Progressive I would say we want to ban
all practices or all claims that are not
based on excellent environmental
performance also we want to ban claims
based on offsetting because it's
extremely misleading to Consumers we
want to ban early obsolescence of
products and we want to be sure that
products are repairable according to law
now what is this update necessary you
know today in Market there are millions
of different labels on the products and
consumers notice them but they are not
sure if they could trust them so there
are eco-friendly
natural product there are lots of lots
of different marks and we want to be
sure when consumer sees uh something
that label like that to be sure that
this is really environmentally friendly
product the producers are very wise for
themselves because they are aware of the
fact that
consumers are more and more aware of
importance of uh in my environment clean
environment and our goals and green
transition and they're even ready to pay
a little bit more if they are sure that
this is this product is eco-friendly
so it means that producer can earn more
money if they put some claim but
unfortunately behind that kind of claim
sometimes is nothing so it means that
for example two of us can work as a
producers of something in a big company
and I'm the one who gives you a
certificate that something is
environmentally friendly so we want to
make order in this Jungle of labels so
that consumers will have a
uh uh confidence that they they buy
something that is really eco-friendly
and that they also have their share in
uh green transition yeah so this new
conscience of the consumers looking for
uh eco-friendly products is more out of
uh out of environmental conscience
rather than financial concern you mean
yeah of course I mean of nobody wants to
pay product too much but as I said since
uh consumers are more responsible when
they are buying and they want to have
their share uh in a green transition
they are willing to buy to pay a little
bit more if they are 100 sure that this
is true that this claim is saying about
excellent environmental performance you
consulted in the industry
Representatives while working on this
update and what do they think about this
new laws are they on board well I think
that they are aware of the fact that the
the things have to change
so the impression that you got from yeah
yeah we want to help I would say uh
those who are doing uh uh business in uh
environmentally friendly way now and
they are not able to present themselves
in a right way because there are lots of
false claims and uh you know some some
industry which is not so a progressive
and environmentally friendly if they
they say they are and there is nobody to
approve that well then uh those who are
really
good producers that are deserved uh
praise from us they they uh
just are left in in a market like
everybody else
false claim is a problem only on the
grain sector or do you also see that in
products like food false claims for like
a product that has additional iron or
which is gluten free and it's not true
yeah this is totally uh another sector
and I would say that unfortunately there
are lots of misleading claims
and when it comes to food
and this is also something that we
should work on because
uh you know sometimes or very often
people buy special kind of food because
of health reasons uh or because of
prevention so I would say that this is a
double crime because if somebody is
already ill and takes something uh
thinking that he's buying something
about is good for his health and and it
is not good then it's it's really a
double crime so is there something for a
sin to tackle this the issue yeah yeah I
was a shadow rapper tour on a farm to
Fork report and uh
this is we will change 27 different laws
in this term when it comes to a food
chain to food production and
declarations and everything so we are
making a order in this in this sector
this is also work in progress yeah yeah
moving back to the update of the list of
banned commercial practices does it go
in the seminar Direction has the right
to repair legislation which Parliament
has been asking for years and it's
finally in the making yeah
let's say that we have the same aim in
these two files we want to
make a possible refurbishment to to make
possible that this way of doing things
right now like buying using for a short
period of time and throwing away is
behind us and I would say that maybe uh
we are with this going a little bit
backwards like we used to do things in
60s and 70s in the last century which
was much more responsible to the planet
now this products are
affordable
and also spare parts are sometimes
pricey and consumers decide to buy a new
product because you know if you for
example
call a service and they say the the
spare part is 60 percent of a whole
product you will start to think well
maybe in few months or few weeks I will
have a new uh problem with this product
and again new 60 of
a new product and then people decide to
buy totally new and discard this product
which could be maybe easily repaired now
why is so expensive to repair a product
to fix something when it breaks down
well I don't want to be a promoter of a
conspiracy theories but you know it
seems like it was a whole system that
made us to buy new products producers
even have when you ask them why do they
do this they say because consumers
always want a new design I can I can
understand that if we talk about for
example women's shoes but I'm not sure
that anybody bought a washing machine
because new design is on the market so
the system now works in a way that
repairs shops and the number of repair
shops are declining every year so in
smaller cities in across the European
Union sometimes it's impossible to find
a spare original spare parts
also now it's impossible to use other
spare but you I mean you have to have
Originals spare part if you want a
service to to repair your product
then
also as we said the price of spare parts
is too high so the whole system works
the consumer wants to buy and I mean not
want to buy but is uh yeah forced to buy
a new product because it's impossible to
repair even though more than 70 percent
of consumers prefer to repair than to
buy a new one how can you make sure that
the prices will go down as well
I think that the time has come that
everybody
understands that this way of doing
things is impossible and it's not
sustainable if you look at the
uh outcome of the votes in the
parliament so left and right center
extreme left and right uh almost uh all
of us voted in the same way when when we
talk about this file empowering
consumers in green position so it means
that we are all aware how important is
to to change things in a way that we
have affordable
products and that we have
we don't have to repair them because
after two or three years majority of
products are broken down when you think
about guarantee which is expires after
two years I mean this is surprise
surprise after these two years very
often your Appliance is dead if industry
is focused on
production of spare parts
and if they see the possibility of
income in that part I think that we can
all all be satisfied
because industry will have their
interest of course consumers will have
their interest and the environment is
going to be improved
when we think about this update on this
regulation and the new right to repair
together with the common Charter all of
this comes down to given that the
consumers the opportunity to buy less at
the end I understand this is good for
the environment it's good for consumers
pockets as well but it also has an
impact on industry when we talk about
common charger I have to say that this
process was going on for 10 years
because at the beginning commission
asked the industry is it possible for
you to have a deal between yourselves
how this common charger should look like
of course nobody wanted to change their
comment their charge everybody wanted
that their charger becomes a common
charger
and in the end when we realized that
this is that the deal is absolutely
impossible then uh Engineers
had a discussion and then they said this
should be this a common charger should
look like the solution was imposed yeah
so it means that industry of course when
they have uh financial interest which is
so high they are not so willing to
cooperate in a fast manner but uh in the
end as I said I believe that the time
has come that also the industry
understands that
the changes are needed and that they are
ready to
make their contribution to a better
environment in the future and we will
have a common charger for all electronic
devices and appliances from next to year
right next year yeah and I have to say
that this is a quite specific uh issue
this is one specific thing that was
extremely important I would say to our
citizens because I think that people are
totally Fed Up of this situation for
example when you come to work you
realize that your mobile phone has six
percent of battery and then who has a
charger for this mobile or that mobile
from next year the only question that
you will have to ask does anybody has a
child uh have a charger
so it's a it's a big change well we've
been talking about all sorts of products
but we're also consumers of services
when you open a bank account when you
buy a train ticket or you book a hotel
and are we also protected as a consumers
as the European Union also protecting
our rights as consumers when it comes to
Services uh of course we are working on
uh Services also to protect our
consumers for example uh just now uh EU
rules came into Force when it comes to
rail passengers also when it comes to
airplanes
passengers have to know their rights
what is going on if the flight is
delayed
one of great achievements is to roam
like at home but there are only fairs
yeah I think that communication with our
citizens is the most important when it
comes to Consumer right protection
action because we always get a feedback
what's going on in every field you know
when we come when we talk about products
or services or whatever
and that is our uh way how to do things
to hear uh what what what needs needs to
be improved and I'm uh quite satisfied
and proud about the achievements uh when
we talk about consumer protection I I
have to say one personal remark you know
when I'm in a street at home in Croatia
when people in a street recognize me and
when they say thank you for the roaming
I'm the most proud person in the world
that's great thank you very much from
the silver square co-working space in
Brussels I'm marcelisoten and this is
billiana boxan a leading MEP on consumer
protection
thank you thank you
[Music]